louis aliot oui le nouvel homme fort de
perpignan louis aliot qui a remporté
cette élection municipale après trois
tentatives
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur arte france donc
troisième tentative première victoire
comment vous avez réussi à convaincre
les perpignanais de voter en votre
faveur
goûtez ça fait longtemps que je me
plante et je pense avoir trouvé aussi
une équipe et cette équipe aujourd'hui
elle va être en charge de la mairie et
je pense que perpignan devait tourner
une page c'était un vieux système
politique et je pense que voilà il
fallait du renouveau il fallait des
nouveaux visages
il fallait un nouveau maire et c'était
le moment ou jamais de le faire un front
républicain a été mise en place pour
faire barrage aux au rassemblement
national c'est la stratégie qui est
menée depuis 2002 maintenant à cette
stratégie clairement elle ne fonctionne
plus aujourd'hui mais je pense qu'elle
s'est effondré après à perpignan puisque
la seule contre tous et il faut vraiment
le dire on a réussi à l'emporter ça
prouve que ce front républicain et est
une escroquerie politique il ne repose
sur rien et que les gens qui appellent
systématiquement à barrer la route à
quelqu'un eh bien les citoyens n'en
veulent plus et la preuve c'est ce soir
et j'espère que ça servira de leçon à
tous les autres marine le pen vous a
félicité ce soir elle vous a félicité
d'avoir réussi à rassembler même la
gauche ici à perpignan ce sont des mots
qui vous touche de la part de la
présidente du rassemblement national
bien sûr elle est à la tête très
certainement aujourd'hui du plus grand
parti de france
même si les municipales ne sont pas de
notre élection on va quand même le dire
mais il ya des départementales à
à défendre il ya des régionales voilà la
présidentielle à venir et elle sait
pouvoir compter
j'allais dire sur des cadres fidèle et
je pense que toutes les équipes partout
en france seront désormais je vais dire
au soutien de toute la politique à mener
tout le renouveau politique à faire en
france aujourd'hui
dernière question à louis aliot à quoi
va ressembler le perpignan de louis
aliot a seulement permis en plus sûres
où les jeunes auront enfin un avenir
plus propre aussi et un perpignan qui
aura valeur d'exemple en matière de
qualité de vie
parce qu'on a vu à dire une situation
paradoxale on est une très belle ville
un patrimoine magnifique
on est dans une situation géographique
elle aussi privilégiées et pourtant on
cumule tous les mauvais chiffres
eh bien il faut sortir de cette de cette
chose là et je pense que mon équipe et
moi même serons à la hauteur de la
situation
commencé le travail dès la semaine
prochaine dès la semaine prochaine on
sera installé à partir de samedi et dès
dimanche au travail si beaucoup et louis
louis aliot donc nouveau maire donc de
la ville de perpignan donc vous l'avez
entendu louis aliot qui est bien va se
mettre au travail assez rapidement qui a
répondu donc qui est qu'ils avaient bien
célèbre cette victoire à la mairie de
perpignan avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'humilité ce soir merci beaucoup et
nadège nadège adhara zac en direct de
perpignan